a lot of people think that okay if i
have a faith-based channel i need to be
talking about the bible i need to be
talking about you know a sin i need to
be talking about these things and yes
they do need to be talked about but what
i love so much about what you've really
done in your ecosystem of the entire uh
justin coo
business is that you've expanded out
your reach to be able to influence in
the church in a larger capacity because
of the skills that you were learning you
couldn't just go and say hey can i do
this podcast for you until you had
already done your own podcast
so maybe you have thought about starting
a youtube channel that is around your
faith or maybe right now you're actually
already in a ministry position and you
want to diversify you want to build your
influence online well i'm excited
because on today's episode of the
youtube made simple show i have my
friend justin here of
justincoo.com and the youtube channel
and we're gonna be breaking down how he
makes money as a faith-based channel all
that's coming up right now
[Music]
so justin i'm so excited for you to be
on the youtube made simple show today
we're going to be breaking down uh how
you're making money as a faith-based
youtuber but not even that as a content
creator in this faith space as an
influencer and because of the think
community i know that we do have a lot
of people who want to share their faith
online or want to grow their influence
because they're already in a faith-based
position like a pastor or they're
writing books or they're doing
devotionals or something like that so
i'm excited you're here today but let's
go to break down the story of how you
even got started on youtube sharing your
faith yeah so i was in my first year of
marriage i just moved across the country
to start this brand new job
it felt like a dream job at the time i
was invited to teach at a very small
bible college and at that time that
season of my life i was really wanting
to step in and to grow in the area of my
gifting of of teaching i always felt
like that's probably something that i
feel like i could do but i never really
got an invitation to do it so i'm
stepping into this thing and like let's
be real a lot of you guys know if you're
in ministry that the the pay is not
always proportionate to the amount of
work that you put in um this was my
highest paying job ever in my life at
that point uh 25 years old and i was
making a grand total of i think it was
44 000
yes um so let's you know like it it was
nice that i could finally pay my bills
but there was not much else that i could
do with that type of income so i
actually ended up going onto the
internet and trying to figure out what
are other ways that i could do this i
had a had an experience with a student
of mine michael troynowski iii
a student who came to the school because
he wanted to serve the lord and do all
these things it was awesome story but
the way that he found his way at the
school was because of a youtube video he
decided to become a christian because of
a youtube video and it was the first
time i ever heard of this idea i'm like
oh my goodness this is radical this is
crazy the internet can be used to really
serve people at a deep and meaningful
level and so i was thinking okay if that
happened for him how can i utilize the
internet in a way that i can spread my
message or the message i believe that
god has given me
and maybe
maybe there's a little bit of a dream
turn it into a business yeah and you
know the context for this moment in my
life i had never owned a camera really i
had a gopro you know i would do like a
you know film my workout sets at the gym
or something you know something vain
like that but i never took a video
editing course graphic design course
business like none of that i didn't have
that context um but i did find a little
course you might have heard of it once
called vra
it was a very little course at the time
yeah as i said so it's a whole academy
yeah like there's more to buying now
there was only one thing and it was the
beta version of the thing and it was a
thing that broke many times yes um you
click a link and it wouldn't work and
i'd have to email heather and be like
hey um i think that this thing so
anyways i'll fix now yeah it works now
you can buy it and it'll be great
um so i launched into this and it gave
me a framework to kind of begin
thinking around what does it look like
for me to step into the space as someone
who has more experience as a
communicator in the faith space but not
as a content creator
started making content uh i made a
commitment that i would do one piece of
content per week much like we would do
in the in the church space you do a
sermon once a week or something like
that
when i would think about my goals in
growing the channel i had to
conceptualize it in a way that i would
understand i would think about it like a
church plant
i knew how hard it is to grow a church
to grow a ministry because i was part of
a church plant i knew that after a year
you know you're not really expecting
massive turnout yet it's a long-term
vision and so i thought you know i it
was new year's around that time i was
writing goals in my journal and i
remember writing down 250 i felt that if
i could work and put in the the time and
energy to do one video per week and at
the end of a year i have a community of
250 people i'm like that's better than
any church i could ever think of started
on 250 and after i hit
period on on that note pad the holy
spirit's like no dream bigger i'm like i
already felt like i was dreaming big so
i doubled the number 500 okay whatever
come to realize that i was dreaming far
too small god wanted me to dream much
bigger at the end of my first year 10
000 subscribers now we're in somewhere
115 000 subscribers or something along
those lines and it just it blew my mind
what could happen when i really leaned
into this online space we talked about
how there's you know videos one of the
most powerful if not the most powerful
medium to spread a message right now and
that's what i've seen in my journey
and so you know starting off working
after hours you know i would work my
full-time job come home spend 20 hours a
week or so working on the next piece of
content
it was it was a stressful thing 10
months into it finally decided all right
i'm going all in ended up resigning my
position i felt like god was leading me
to do so resigned my position
told my wife give me one year one year
of just dedicated hard work and energy
she would then you know foot the bill
and
and like
crazy enough it worked uh we're here now
five years after the fact and now we
with my first kid my wife is able to
take her first year off of off of job
off the job because of kind of the
business and the ecosystem that we've
built through the skills that we've
developed in creating content online so
all that to say is it possible as a
faith-based influencer i think it is i
don't think you're ever gonna be the joe
rogan you're not gonna be you know the
casey neistat which is who i was
aspiring to be at the time but you're
not going to have maybe you won't have
maybe you will i won't speak that over
you you will um but i'm not and i don't
think that i ever will be the millions
and millions of subscribers but that
doesn't mean that i can't do something
meaningful and it doesn't mean that i
can't live a life that's sustainable at
the same time so good and i want to talk
about that journey really in getting to
um you said you know you started at the
most you had ever made 44 000 a year in
a great job you know doing doing the
work and um but now i mean i don't if
you're comfortable with sharing i mean
you're you're over six but you're in six
figures now
still doing great work and doing it
online so i want to break down four um
faith-based channels because there is
this misconception and i want to talk
about this because you dove into trying
these different things that first didn't
work so i want to talk about that and
then i want to talk about how you are
actually making an income right now
solely off of what you're doing with
content i would say it's broader than
youtube youtube is the way it is the in
and it's what helped you get there but
now we've broken it and made it broader
and i want people who are wanting to go
down this path to see that there's more
than just one way so talk about at the
very beginning um obviously there's ad
revenue you can get from youtube views
but that's not how you're making your
living so let's talk about maybe at the
beginning and then we'll pivot into what
you're doing now initially the belief is
ad revenue is the way then obviously you
you just watch anyone talk about what
average
ad revenue is
you really you really quickly realize
unless you're doing like literally
millions of views
per video it's not sustainable uh and
then you you dive in and you find out
vra is available and vra gives you a
system to work with and a
much better way to get sustainability
and that's to affiliate marketing
plugging products on amazon and things
like that that didn't work for me and
the reason why is because i'm i'm trying
to be very conscious of how
uh
christians are perceived on the internet
whether rightfully so or not um
the televangelist who passes the bucket
saying give me your money god's gonna
bless you kind of a thing like i never
wanted to be that person i don't want to
perpetuate that stereotype and so i
never wanted to be able to
for someone to have a
footing to say oh that's what they're
doing he's just doing this for the money
so i never wanted to do
affiliates also because like what does
you know this beauty product have
anything to do with what i'm trying to
accomplish on the internet or what is
this you know this course it just it
just felt icky it felt weird that didn't
work either
the the first i think success that i
stumbled across
was a thing called patreon which at the
time was not like uh an accepted
practice it is i think so now i think
people get it now that patreon if you
don't know yeah they break it down
because some people don't know what
patreon is and how it can be so what is
patreon yeah patreon is like a goodwill
machine it's a way for you to say hey i
see this creator i love what they're
doing and i want to be a part of it uh
whether that's like like i want to
support the production
of a show like i can literally weigh in
and say this is kind of a topic that i'm
thinking of or i want to nudge the show
in one direction or the other it's a way
for you to to give to pledge a monthly
amount or on a per creation amount um to
be able to support a creator and i felt
that that was a way that people would
understand what i'm
attempting to do yeah in in in our
circles in the faith-based circles tithe
or offering whether you whatever
whatever your theological stance on is
the idea of giving monthly to support
ministry is very acceptable practice
it's not sleazy it's not salesman-like
um if you present it in the right way
and so being able to rally support
around the shared mission of what i was
attempting to accomplish at the that
christian vlogger stage of my journey
attempting to take the gospel to the
internet to be able to serve young
adults specifically that was something i
found that other people were also
noticing was an underserved area
and so being able to find people who who
quite literally maybe didn't even watch
my content but because they heard me
present at a church or at a conference
or they just followed me on social media
they're like you know what
i see the need for something like this
and i know that i can't do it and i know
that no one's doing it in the space but
i'm glad that someone like justin exists
and is doing it let me donate that was a
massive leap forward and that that got
me to my first let's call it thousand
dollars a month like it was it was able
to to to sustain like
buying food and you know like all the
important things and it was like oh this
is really brilliant because this is
something i can depend on i'm not having
to go uh search for the next you know
brand deal i'm not having to beg and
plead the the algorithm gods to to bless
me with a viral video or anything like
it's something that's dependable whether
my videos get a dozen views or 12 000
views it wouldn't matter because there's
something i can count on
um
in that journey
i had some of the most important advice
that i could be given when it came to
the patreon economy
i had at that time
formatted my patreon so that it was a
monthly charge because you know the idea
is like oh it's kind of like church it's
just like you're giving a prescribed
amount but patreon has the ability to do
a per creation basis versus a monthly
one and the advice that i was given is
to shift as quickly as i could to a per
creation basis interesting that was
really scary because i'm like well what
if i get sick or what if i don't you
know like the the fear was well what if
i don't deliver enough contents like
then i'm going to losing money which i
think that's certainly true
but i think it's easier for your patrons
or
potential patrons to realize hey you
know what i'm supporting a specific
episode
i'm supporting a very specific show
versus just like i'm just giving money
and who knows what happens
the other benefit is is that you can
actually start to work around some of
the other elements of your shows um i do
like a two or three hour
interview
for for most of my my shows nowadays um
but
that is not what the content ends up
being you know a three-hour episode on
youtube would be far too exhausting
unless you're joe rogan um and so what i
end up doing is turning three hours of
content into a 45 minute or a one-hour
episode well there's two hours worth of
really fantastic conversation that just
dies on the cutting floor
well if you're doing a per content
creation you can do a patreon charge for
the actual edited episode of that uh
interview yeah you can also do an
additional charge for the unedited
unscripted full-length start to finish
episode of that
version of that interview as well as
number three what a lot of my viewers
were asking for was kind of like my
commentary on the episode what am i
learning if i look at the episode a
month later and i've had the time to
digest it what am i thinking about what
is kind of my more un unfiltered
thoughts about it and really quickly you
could turn one patreon charge into three
four if you have more creativity
multiple different things um and so like
patreon quickly became a way for me to
make my channel at least at a break-even
point
that's amazing wow i'm like soaking in
all of the things because that's not a
strategy that we currently use at think
and so just hearing the way that you
know immediately what came to mind is
when there's a good movie i go and pay
for it at the at the um movie theater
and i buy the popcorn and i buy that
like it's the same type of experience
you're just bringing that online and
you're going deeper with your audience
around the topics that they are
interested in not just some
regular you know whatever you want to
talk about but very much specific to
what they want so you started with
patreon so that's one strategy talk
about then how you've now gone from that
break-even point to the way that you're
making a full-time living off of content
creation in the faith-based space one of
the most important things was i had a
[ __ ] i had to have a shift in the way i
was thinking about what i was doing
online
i believed for many years that in order
to be a full-time content creator
full-time youtuber that the money that i
had to make had to be directly from
youtube whether that's an ad revenue
affiliate it had to be because of the
youtube videos i had created and that
type of thinking
uh it felt like at least in my
experience i don't know how it's for
others but for me it it i hit a ceiling
pretty quickly i had that leap that
initial uh jump in patreon with people
who supported my mission but
kind of like six months into that
journey like growth plateaued hardcore
and the reality is is like three years
later it's more or less within the same
general range yeah it's not like blown
up um so the number of people who bought
the vision and are in it like they're in
it like i found my people already
but i was still trapped in order to
produce this content i had to still work
for hours and hours and hours to film to
to edit to theory craft what the next
episode would be and i found myself
working uh what's the phrase i found
myself working in my business and not on
my business on yeah in is like you're
doing the work on is like your your
vision you're going out there yeah and
because i was spending still 10 15 20
plus hours every week editing my own
videos like i was limited
so i had to do what felt like a major
risk i had to find how do i bring
someone on the team and how do i hire
and rightfully compensate someone
for them working on my content but that
was scary because that's a third a half
maybe all of my patronage yeah um and
and quite literally like there's there
are many times where it's all of the
money that i would make on patreon but
what it did is it freed me up in a
number of different ways one i could
actually be present as a husband i could
actually have time to take care of my
health uh and so like life wasn't quite
at the red alert level anymore but also
i now had more time to think about like
well how do i dream of the bigger
picture now if i'm not just working on
the next video i can start to think
about like how do i actually turn
what i've learned on this platform for
multiple years the skills that i'm
developing to start
like leveraging that for other people
so i could outsource an entire month's
worth of editing
and use that money there but then i
could free myself up to say okay how do
i
trade what i have to be able to
drive revenue so i'll give you an
example there's a a a branch in my
church denomination i'm a seventh-day
adventist there's a branch in my church
that was looking for contents for young
adults for example
i basically pitched them hey what would
it look like if i did like a 40 i think
40 or 45 episode podcast
on your behalf i know that you need
content for this here's i understand
your mission i understand what you're
trying to do i pitched this project and
i think we had some we were able to be
given a large budget and all i had to do
was sit down and interview people like
40 times which took me let's call it 25
hours worth of work so it would be three
or four days worth of work but that
contract would buy me months
worth of runway so now i could spend one
week working on their project
effectively and outsource the rest of my
work and i would still have weeks if not
months to be able to think of the next
thing
and then so we did that with a podcast
we've done that with a documentary we've
done that with photography deals we've
done that with kind of like one-off
contracting videography you know
jobs i'm able to trade one day's worth
of work for a week's worth of time or a
month's worth of time or something along
those lines and so now i'm able to be
able to start building a team around
myself so i can actually do this work
sustainably it's so amazing that you
even brought that up and
a lot of people think that okay if i
have a faith-based channel i need to be
talking about the bible i need to be
talking about you know a sin i need to
be talking about these things and yes
they do need to be talked about but what
i love so much about what you've really
done in your ecosystem of the entire uh
justin coo
business is that you've expanded out
your reach to be able to influence in
the church in a larger capacity because
of the skills that you were learning you
couldn't just go and say hey can i do
this podcast for you until you had
already done your own podcast and so i i
want you if you're a faith-based
listener um and and hear me if you're
not use this as
the same principles uh just the idea
that it doesn't have to be just on
youtube it doesn't have to be just what
you're getting through affiliates or
brands or making your own courses or
content it doesn't have to be that it
can be using the skills that you're
gaining the knowledge that you have to
be able to go in and even pitch that
option because you know what their
vision is right you could be using this
if you are in mountain
if you're a mountain climbing or you're
in i'm just thinking of things but
there's so many things if you understand
the mission of what you're helping with
there's so many opportunities there's so
many pieces of opportunity so
i want to know because i know right now
you've really grown your influence in
the space you've really grown to be
someone who people see as
someone who understands social media
content and understands how to get
content out to an audience there are
people that right now are vocationally
in ministry right that's what they're
doing and like you said they're super
busy you're coaching and training these
individuals what's some advice you have
for them as they are deciding you know
maybe their church has a youtube channel
which is their sunday service and that's
all they're producing right now what is
some advice that you have to someone
vocationally who wants to expand past
the pulpit like what do they need to do
to be able to grow into being an
influencer influencer online to help to
move their mission forward well i think
specifically in the faith context we
have to be
less romantic about the church
experience and and cobit has has made
that a lot easier to be less romantic
about that is to realize that listen
like
maybe the the the church model of today
continues into the future maybe it
doesn't but the need to communicate the
gospel is is an evergreen skill like
it's something that you're always going
to be able uh to find like maybe not
always find an audience but like this is
something that you should always be
doing and so being able to to realize
that hey you know what it's okay for you
as a minister of the gospel to spend
serious time thinking about growing your
skills in in the area of content
creation in delivery on video things
like that um you've spent hundreds if
not thousands if not tens of thousands
of hours honing in the skill of
presenting at a pulpit um and that's
served you well i believe um but the
skill is different on camera like you
know cause you you remember that first
zoom weekend that you had to do church
and you're just like this is the most
weird and awkward thing in the world but
here's the thing every church is feeling
that way
and if you are able to uh to
differentiate yourself in the in the
faith space as someone who does command
an audience with a microphone and a
camera who's able to speak in these
areas like you're going to be able to
serve the body of christ in in a much
grander way than maybe you would have if
you only prioritize the physical service
does this mean that we're completely
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
of course not like we need community we
need these these in real life personal
you know you know
meeting spaces but like what we can do
on the internet is absolutely incredible
i'll give you an example so when i was
in the that christian vlogger phase i
would create my videos we'd do questions
and answers questions asked about the
bible things like that and that would
have just one line in my bio where hey
if you want to sign up for bible studies
here's the link
in a calendar year in 12 months i wasn't
promoting it there was no audible call
to action like hey click the link it was
just literally you had to click
see more in order to even read it and
then you had to click it
i had 2
300 people sign up for personal bible
studies in a 12 month period
like
that's amazing and if you're at a church
and you don't have yet a well thought
out strategy when it comes to your
digital missions yet like
this is the type of opportunity that
we're missing out on like this is
absolutely crucial i just started in the
last like two
three months i can experiment on
instagram where i'm starting to explore
what does it look like to create
carousels for the purpose of creating
you know bible-based content and i
started to include one of those like
community text links like hey text this
word to this number and you'll sign up
for my my saturday morning bible studies
i regularly have 30 people in on a zoom
type bible study that i've only been
sourced from instagram and so what i'm
saying here is that the internet is not
a second rate mission field
if anything it's a first-rate mission
field because who comes to church if not
christians already so you're preaching
to the choir which is needed and it's
important and i'm and i'm not knocking
it but the kinds of people who don't go
to church but still have the kinds of
questions that the scriptures speak to
they're here
and if you can figure out how to show up
in a way that's not intrusive that's not
obnoxious but actually serves them and
reaches them and serves them well
like
you're going to be doing something that
no one else is doing
wow thank you so much for that and i
want to go deeper here on uh the youtube
made simple show in doing different
types of content creators i love that we
got to start this series in the ministry
because there is the misconception that
you can't make money if you're doing
ministry online and uh you are a
testament to that exact thing so where
can people go if they want to go deeper
in learning how you're doing this if
they'd like to get coaching from you
what does that look like
for what you're doing uh if you're
wanting coaching or to book me to speak
at a church or conference justincoo.com
is the place to go to if you want to see
the kind of work that i'm experimenting
with and playing around with on youtube
it's justin kuh instagram is at jaeku
and i just lost launched a tick tock
justin coo as well um and
maybe this is a way for me to break it
for the first time publicly so it forces
me out of my like thinking about phase
but i'm i'm going to be starting the
justin coo experiment which will be like
a podcast and youtube channel where it's
explicitly exploring what does it look
like to be a content creator in the
faith space specifically how do we
navigate growing an audience uh growing
revenue like all the things where we'll
have like a private community like all
of that kind of stuff it's it's going to
launch hopefully before this episode
goes public if not just follow me on the
socials and you'll know when it goes
publicly yeah i don't say and all these
links will be updated down below uh if
you are watching on youtube or if you're
listening on the podcast well i want to
thank you again for being here for being
my first of this new series that we just
decided to start as of right now i was
like we should do a whole series while
you were talking so brand new series
about bringing different types of
creators and um and debunking the myths
of that i'm just making this up on the
fly but i think it's fun sounds great um
you're watching the youtube made simple
show make sure if you are into this type
of content that you subscribe and we
have another episode that happens every
two weeks so make sure you are here for
that episode thank you for being a part
of this community and let me know in the
comments section what was your aha
moment or what other type of creators
would you like me to bring on this show
and what myths should i debunk on this
show thank you for being a part of what
we're doing here at think and we will
catch you on the next episode are you
ready to start or grow your youtube
channel do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs
just like you grow their influence with
video register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
you